io veramente nella mia vita non voglio
più fare paura
[Musica]
il sistema
poi però di essere un po di tedesco
come si chiama jacopo
[Musica]
così niente
dai dai dai va bene adesso si sono poi
ha paura
[Musica]
ma mi sono più umano
[Applauso]
meno male poi si sa noi ne sei alzato
scarto fine sei carto fine se il
cartoccio in piccolo quando pensi di
trovare dei ragni invece trovo un
bambino catto fine ti chiami ma essere
mio figlio io non aveva figli genitori
ad uno genitori due all'esperimento
iniziamo non sapere neanche cosa fare ma
facciamo oggi totò e aver riportato
carto finite sarebbe pino pluri
intelligente perché parlare molte lingue
io parlo francesi in facenti mai forse
meraviglioso io parlo italiano in
italiano
gli italiani in italiano doveva dire io
parlava i tedeschi in tedesco e a
parlare in tedesco
papin a parlare tutte le lingue quindi
oggi parlare con cabine e spiegare
bambini come funziona le fasi
comunicanti fabris ambienti portare anzi
va a vedere tubero kart of two chiamare
in ambienti dio portare portare
materiale chiamare insegnanti che
portare a materiale oggi totò per
spiegare come funzionare vasi
comunicanti e tutti voi che sarà
inferiore all'ora prenderà il bicchiere
è mettere come quella alta brocca e
mettere qua liquido dovere passare da
una all'altra senza toccare brock
come funziona non sarete born to be
multifunzione pacchetto globale vi
invita ad amici quando le sere in classe
oppure tu passare liquido da 44 oggi ce
la facciamo passare dentro il camice
secondo se ci bagniamo il premio le
motoria fatto molto peggio passare tubo
dare una mano ad ottavia passare tutto
venga qua
che è la mente di due giusto quindi
facciamo che fa lui essere mente adesso
totoro e mostra rete come funzionare
principio fatto fino adesso racconto
dovete finire basta specialmente adesso
che avete capito come funzionare vasi
comunicanti noi giocare insieme al
grande laboratorio dei nostri questo che
avere in bagno car tutine essere il
primo gioco a tema scientifico
collezionabile quindi incredibile perché
oggi noi montale aprirebbe va tutto bene
bisogna prima quanti anni aveva il
cartofilo 88 è a posto
ringrazia molisani per aver provviste di
elementi adesso vedere e far esperimento
scientifico tatuare avere uova per fare
nascere mostri questa sai che cosa
essere e sai cosa che totò è bravo se
noi fare bravo totale girarsi e carto
fine affinatore e colla che essere qua 3
uova e ce l'abbiamo cisterna la cisterna
quale essere secondo lei cisterna essere
esattamente questo tono molto bravo
collegare tubo bene stare lì non fare
nient'altro che però adesso non
esagerare totore quello che abbiamo
fatto altri stare ancora di abitando
libro bene abitare secondo me era meglio
evitare prima ma fare niente assieme ad
esso che noi avere montato tutto quanto
come modo giusto bisogna iniziare a fare
nascere nostri mostri inserire mostro in
camera di nascita perfetto dove inserire
acqua in cisterne sarebbe pure avere
capelli bianchi ma cosa volere bambino
scherzato non fare casino che poi il
dover pulire io molto bene guardare bene
siringa mentre riempirsi condove che
tira
babbo perfetto riflettere le operazioni
in modo tale da riempire totalmente
acqua di cisterna
adesso avere mostro che sta nascendo noi
però non fare niente per 10 minuti
quindi togliere nostro e mettere altra
cisterna perché noi farle nascere un
altro no non toglie che corretto è
sempre dirigente di testa adesso noi
lasciare è permesso interne interne the
moscow adesso guardare se esperimento
essere riuscito molto bene noi avere
trovato questo essere questo essere
all'occhio averle prese con netto 4 fa
gelli e sarei questo qua noi aveva
trovato solo due di 24 perché socio nei
24 però essere al mio preferito cornetto
storia verrà adesso due mostri una testa
noi questo dobbiamo fare adesso dobbiamo
conservare i nostri morti perché molti
vanno conservati come creature
mitologiche va bene quindi noi dove a
creare il liquido amniotico dove
riversare in meta con tenuto a fiumi
pisa 20 passare ricarica questa essere
ricarica perché tu poter prendere mostra
è anche a parte è qua dentro noi avere
nostro ma non usare adesso aveva mostro
ma avere soprattutto cosa che noi serve
il colorante così tu poter far colore
diverso da quello di totò recapito
niente è più colorato può essere
colorato per potere ammesso coach abbia
mondani de manera fare una adesso ne
aveva creato ambiente favorevole
nutritivo per i nostri nostri quindi noi
inserire mostro all'interno di liquido
ringraziamo lisciani per averci dato
mostri così belli quindi noi aveva
finito qua video essere contento jacopo
andare bene no lo chiamano i più dai
dobbiamo cercare di più è largamente noi
giochiamo di più voi potete vedere al 3
milioni da toria perché può esserci
playlist di video può esserci altro
video essere altro video molto bello
guardare e qua invece esserci il canale
è finito nel giocare di più con questi
roberto
tutto è fatto male